Hélène sourit à Nicolas
elle l'embrasse
on a longtemps imaginé que les textes
étaient écrits à l'américaine par une
batterie de scénaristes payé au gag et à
la réplique la mécanique est plus simple
et moins cher Jean-Luc Azoulay plante le
décor des 50 premiers épisodes d'une
série invente les intrigues au jour le
jour et passent le relais pour Hélène le
schéma est désormais figé 8 personnes
âges 4 lieux immuables 22 minutes d'une
seule et même aventure des composés en 7
séquences cet Emmanuel Mottaz une ex
chanteuse abbé qui signe les dialogues
ils peuvent nous attendre
il va nous attendre je crois pas qu'on
aura y aller
tendrement
il faut y aller
mais un tout petit moment seul avec toi
c'est certainement plus beau cadeau tu
puisses me faire Hélène
elle l'embrasse
[Musique]
sans bien sûr se prendre la tête
là-dessus mais je pense qu'en effet je
veux dire on écrit on écrit pas pour soi
je veux dire on écrit pour les enfin moi
j'écris pour les autres et c'est vrai
que si je peux être
bien juste en tous les cas ça me fait
plaisir j'espère que les gens le
comprennent comme ça je pense que tous
les jeunes qui regardent et les moins
jeunes et les plus jeunes qui regardent
Hélène et les garçons aiment parce que
justement il y a toujours une moralité
il y a toujours un message qui n'est pas
intellectuel parce que c'est le message
de la vie quoi comment on doit se
conduire normalement dans la vie le plus
juste possible par rapport à l'autre et
elle aime et les garçons c'est ça
[Musique]